at 36 years old
i'm going back to haiti for the first
time
i know this sounds strange
how can you go back to somewhere you've
never been
you have to understand as a kid
everything around me was haitian
my mom my dad my grandparents
my aunts my uncles my cousins
patient
so when i say that i'm going back to
haiti for the first time
i'm going back to the asian roots that i
had
when i was growing up
haiti raised me
[Music]
even sometimes when i say that i'm
haitian
there's a hierarchy to this
i have a hard time saying that i'm
haitian
because i've never been
i might consider myself a haitian but
other people i'm
gonna be like yeah no you're not haitian
to be a haitian you need to
go there every summer i'm haitian i go
there every summer
someone's gonna say to them yeah yeah
i'm here
you're not haitian because you go there
every summer you have to spend six
months there a year
i'm haitian i spend six months there a
year
someone's gonna tell that person six
months a year
but would ask you you just started to do
this three years ago
i did that for like 10 years i bought a
house there
i'm more asian than you and someone's
going to tell that person
10 years ago boo-boo i'm born
there i'm more haitian than you
and then someone's gonna say it it can
keep on going like that
but all them people that i name
all gonna say i'm haitian
and it's in the head
i was born in greenfield park
south shore of montreal quebec
canada
grenfell park which is a city that is
mostly english
south shore mostly french
quebec mostly white
canada mostly canadian
do i identify with that
a part of me identify with that
[Music]
where to lose me is where they really
want to know where i'm from
now i know this disconnect
[Music]
you're saying your quebecois people are
quick to say
yeah but where are you from you claim
you haitians your grandparents or your
parents were quick to say
no you're not you're from canada in the
same thing so you don't belong nowhere
being in
you know second generation you don't
belong
you do not and they make you feel you
don't like you don't belong anywhere
[Music]
everybody i meet in their second gen or
even first gen they all have those
struggles
you'll never be enough
you can't say all your life that you
don't care what people say if people say
that you don't belong you say yeah i
belong
do you really i don't know
maybe you don't
regardless you never stop searching for
a place to call yours
[Music]
the neighborhood i was living in
was amazing we were
the first black family in that suburb
area but it didn't really matter
didn't make me feel any type of way no
difference
but when i went to school yeah i knew i
was different
they made you feel different the
teachers and the kids
the word [ __ ] i learned i learned in
school
oh yeah
fights violence suspensions detentions
racism threats
every day i had to fight
[Music]
i'm 10 years old and for so long
after getting beat
told that you're not going to accomplish
anything
you start to believe it
and i wanted to commit suicide
it's really just a solution right
if i'm a problem
and you remove the problem
then life becomes easier for everyone
including me it would just be
easier if i did not exist
uh
so to make matters worse
my parents they tell me i have to switch
schools
i didn't want to go to this new school
i was comfortable in the trauma because
i knew what to expect
the new school i didn't know anything
about it
i was scared of the unknown
i remember the morning that i woke up to
go to that school i was ready to fight
and i got there the first day a bit
anxious
but i got there and the first thing i
saw
was a lot of black people and i was like
oh
snap i'm home
at this new school
i was around people that looked like me
i could blend in i
was for once in my life
the norm
you know what i don't even really know
why you need your people's acceptance
but what i know though is that it feels
good
to have people that look like you that
go through the same thing
as you uh
that understand what you're living
we in this together
[Music]
no having your people having your back
it feels like a whole army
i had to have that
that saves me
i don't identify with quebec culture
i adapt to it
i have to adapt i talk like them
i act like them it's gonna be easier
and it was i know it would have been
far more worse
[Music]
hey
adapt
adaptation
problem is when i'm around my people
if they sense that you adapted too much
they don't like that
i'm trying to adapt to the quebecers and
my people catch me they're like oh
you're trying to be like them
why do you say this like that like a
white person
i just i'm just adapting it just slip
you know what i mean
and that person makes you feel less than
what you are
you don't want to disappoint your people
it hurts
it cuts deep because as a black person
you don't only carry your own self
you kind of carry your old people with
you
it's not just you presenting yourself
it's you
and the community and you don't want to
misrepresent that community
because you want to bring pride to your
people not shame
and then you start questioning yourself
[Music]
maybe they are not my people
maybe i don't belong
belonging you don't have to do anything
you just are where you were supposed to
be
when your mama yells at you and she
tells you hey can you put that thing
back where it belongs
she doesn't tell you put that thing back
where it fits in
that could be anywhere you know no you
put it where it belongs
it's supposed to be there fitting into
me sounds like
fighting in that's what it sounds like
to me
and that's a bit what it was i had to
fight to fit in
belonging that's belonging i'm supposed
to be there
i had questions about my haitian
identity just because
i had to go back to my roots i had to
know
i feel like i need to belong to that
because it's where i'm from
it's what brought me up it's what i know
the language the ways the stories
the history
all of that is what i know
it's where i'm from my parents are
from there and they nourished me with
that
so i had to know i had to see
[Music]
i get to haiti they look at me
look at the tattoos i got they look at
the dress look at what i wear
and they're like stranger
[Music]
but that falls quick
you explain to them who you are and they
judge your character
uh
[Music]
quickly
you say to them that you really just
want to listen to them
and then they open up everybody's just
they want to tell you the best story
they have and they're cutting each other
off
all those things that my parents and my
uncles
do you know the punctuations the yo stop
talking chill let me talk okay so you
ready for this
like it was the biggest thing he was
about to tell you
but it's really just a normal story it's
amazing just the way the people are
live they want to tell you something i
recognize my people there
[Music]
so
it's like the first time that people
told me that i'm haitian people from
here
that's not you
yeah and i'm like
yeah yeah brother
i'm haitian
you